yeah you can you can cycle a bolt action
rifle pretty quickly but
and and they've caught on to that
because i've seen
um advertising from anti-gun folks
trying to claim that you know bolt
action rifles with a scope and a bipod
are sniper rifles
so you know we need to ban these sniper
rifles they'll ban everything they
like i said the school wouldn't let me
have a padlock you're going to throw it
at somebody yeah well you can throw a
rock at somebody what does it mean yeah
banning things is a weird
man it is a weird conversation because
you don't want to give people
depleted uranium bullets well that's
where things get interesting because
when we were talking about gun control
stuff
a few weeks ago we had luke and luke
loves guns
and i was talking about in you know
urban versus rural issues and i said
what if you're in say new york and you
live in one of these concrete cubicles
stacked on top of some other people
in a place that smells like sour milk
and you know somebody breaks into your
apartment
and you've got uh you know an ar-15 with
maybe like a 308 or something if you
shoot that it's going to go through it's
going to penetrate and you've got tons
of people living around you
and luke immediately and instinctively
said then maybe we don't allow certain
calibers like ah there it is
gun control telling people they can't
have certain weapons because of the
caliber of bullet
it is a challenge i think i you know it
was funny because one of the reasons i
liked bernie sanders years ago was when
he was asked about gun control being
from vermont where people love their
guns
he said it's an urban versus rural issue
he's right
if you live in a tiny concrete cubicle
with paper-thin walls and you can hear
your neighbors banging
you're going to be like i'm pretty glad
they don't have guns because if they
shoot even an
intruder it could penetrate into my
apartment and i got to deal with it
and we've seen it happen with police
shooting into one building and then one
apartment then hitting other
apartments so this makes people in
cities think very very differently about
guns
not to mention they have cops within a
few minutes of them typically
and people who live in rural areas don't
but that's a very difficult challenge
like you mentioned depleted uranium sure
but in a city in general when when like
when the nypd was coming after this dude
who was leaving it was the empire state
building he killed his boss or something
they were trying to shoot at him and
they missed and shot like seven
civilians now that's an issue of
these cops not being trained
particularly we talked about that
earlier that's very interesting
but there there are more ramifications
for living
in an extremely densely populated area
and having guns
the problem i think for these big cities
and for even people who say you
shouldn't have depleted uranium is okay
well then maybe you've got to amend the
constitution first
i understand people might say it's
common sense that you shouldn't have
depleted uranium
and i don't think people should have
depleted uranium bullets
but how do you how do you reconcile that
with a second amendment
saying well the founding fathers never
intended uh it says very generally
the right to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed like you would not want
to give people weapons of mass
destruction but they
had them that's a vague phrase well not
really
they would carpet bomb cities and stuff
they could in the 1700s
yes they could well not really the the
frigates could have
a row dozens of ken's going to kill them
and it would just blanket wipe out these
ports coastal cities
yeah one ship and they were private
individuals who owned these things
so i think the issue i i have with all
of this stuff when
look take a look at like hate crimes for
instance it's already illegal
right they're now saying like oh the
capital insurrection we should make all
these things illegal we should make we
should charge no no we don't need new
laws
enforce the law you already have if
someone takes anything and then kills
somebody with it
it's a crime it's a crime to kill people
but if someone did
sail a boat up on like what's a good
coastal city miami
and just a good coaster yeah just laid
waste to it with artillery fire and then
you're like oops
yes we got to arrest that guy but in the
meantime 60 000 people were killed by
artillery fire like
that's a mistake in the law for letting
that guy get that weapon
well that's a mistake for the coast
guard not intercepting a destroyer with
a bunch of artillery
doesn't even look like the destroyer you
know well that that's just an inherent
problem of reality
like i mentioned the drones what's to
stop someone from taking a drone heaven
forbid and then doing something crazy
with it
and i warned i warned uh uh
people involved with government
regulation on drones in 20
2012 when i said you need to pay
attention to this stuff
because someone could take a
consumer-grade drone and do something
insane with it
and if someone's if someone's standing
outside of new york and they fly a drone
into the city it's done
now you could argue that it's difficult
to come into the city with some kind of
weapon but even then
someone could just walk into new york
with a crazy weapon yeah i lived i lived
in new york when they planted bombs in
jersey city
and manhattan and that was when i was
like i don't want to live in the city
anymore
the police couldn't stop someone from
just carrying in it was it was it was a
pressure cooker
it was like a right you know whatever
and they and they and they blew it up
so it's not even about drones to be
honest it's about the fact that people
can do these things
it's like i mentioned a kid can take
household chemicals go to a school
and mix stuff up in a bathroom and then
also when people start vomiting and
getting sick and potentially die i keep
thinking about mental health
this is whenever i have this
conversation i really get down to it i'm
like well it's a mental health issue if
we're kidding
putting kids on like psychoactives and
like psycho stimulants to
to dull their add or whatever and then
they they have no friends and they have
no love and then they
sure they think they're in a video game
yeah i think there's a big problem with
that
in in modern culture people want to
blame the tool
and not the parenting or the decisions
that that they make and
if you look at most of the mass shooters
i mean adam lanza
sandy hook you know the most memorable
in the in the most awful way obviously
no no real father figure uh
was taking antidepressants and
that's just a recipe for disaster and
unfortunately we spend
all of our time now looking at
how how do we ban the tool that he used
as opposed to looking
at okay how could we have solved that
problem before it happened
same thing with uh parkland i mean if
anybody has read
uh i i would encourage any everybody to
read the book
why meadow died by uh andy pollock
he was meadow's father one of the one of
the
students who was killed in in the
parkland shooting
and he talks about in the book
very detailed about how many
just how how much was overlooked
as far as the the teachers and the
schools for this shooter i mean they
they knew he was a problem
they they tried to get him out of the
school but there were a number of
policies in florida that they were
trying to re-integrate
kids with mental problems
normal school setting and you know they
had this kid who was mentally disturbed
uh with you know kids who had problems
like you know
autism or or other disabilities
and it just didn't work and and they
knew it didn't work
and they did everything they could uh to
prevent it from
they thought that they were doing what
everything that they could to prevent it
from happening but what they were really
doing was setting things up for disaster
i mean
the kid was i i don't know the i don't
remember the exact policy but in broward
county
kids were allowed to have two uh
felony i believe felony convictions per
year
before they would be removed from the
school and that was a reset every year
so
felonies uh i'm sorry misdemeanors no
i was like so you'd have a kid with two
you know kid could have two misdemeanors
as a freshman two misdemeanors as a
sophomore two misdemeanors as a junior
and they would the kid was still allowed
to be in school so
i mean yeah you can look at the the tool
that he used and try to demonize that
and try to spend all of your time and
all this congressional effort trying to
ban this
this uh you know object but meanwhile
they you know they didn't even get rid
of they they were trying to reinstate
uh the sheriff yeah it was just an awful
situation i knew i knew some dude who
worked in a lab
and he told me he didn't think terrorism
was real
and i said that's a bold and ludicrous
statement of course terrorism is real
it's just what do you mean by that what
he said was he didn't think these
stories you hear
about like these attacks are intended to
be
mass destruction and chaos to scare the
population like when we hear about
terror overseas what he was saying was
no those are just attacks on military
installation by military forces against
military forces
the idea that they hate us for our
freedom or that they're trying to
maximize death or scare someone
in a small town and thinking they'll be
a victim he didn't think was real simply
because he worked in a lab
and he said there's a chemical that i
can buy
in bulk for cheap that if you touched
you would get violently ill
and if you got it on your hand it would
seep in your skin you would die and he
was like and if you
anyone in this lab wanted to you could
sprinkle that
in in public in some on a railing for
instance mercury probably kill
50 000 people because it goes into your
skin goes into your system and then
kills you and it's like it never happens
no one ever does that and so he's like
you hear these stories about
a terror attack on a military
installation that what they're trying to
say is the terror
is scaring people into giving in to some
political demand
no these are just people attacking a
military installation to target
the military to target a military target
if it was really about
scaring people into a mask
then then you would see something
particularly insane because
there i'm not i'm not i don't want to
i'm not going to repeat the chemical you
know
he mentioned but he said there is a you
know powdery substance that they work
with in the labs all the time that
they're like you have to be in full gear
and it is it goes into your skin it
kills you
he's like why aren't why aren't you know
why don't people do these things
bio terror it's it's arguably but like
it's always some extremely convoluted
and like difficult exploit like ieds are
more complicated
he was like like building the explosive
is harder than just buying a chemical
and sprinkling it somewhere right
so he thinks it's more about you know
what we were seeing overseas was
directed military attacks against an
adversary
adversarial military against us and the
media frames it as terror
like they're trying to scare civilians
that's not the case
they're not they're not targeting us
here for the most part the point is
i think people look to guns because
they're scary
because it's kind of like a boogeyman
essentially you mentioned it's the tool
right but if you talk to people who own
guns like it's crazy to me that
i can walk around in you know you go to
a gun shop everybody's got a gun
like am i supposed to be worried about
that are there they're genuinely people
who are scared when they see a guy
a random person with a gun there was one
uh video i was watching recently where
there's a guy in
in a store and he's got a a gun just
holds it in his hip
and this woman yelling at him like oh my
god he's got a gun why and they're
yelling
and other people are like who cares who
is this like
urban liberal woman shocked to see a
regular guy with a weapon or there was a
there's photos posted by journalists
where it's like
you'll have a bunch of guys in a store
and they'll have like ars like on their
shoulders
and they're like i can't believe this is
america what are these people doing and
it's like
it's like a normal thing people walking
around with weapons in certain parts of
the country
they're shocked by it they're terrified
but like when the cops do it
i guess now to be honest they're scared
of cops too and they got they want to
get rid of them but
my my my position now on the polish the
police thing is like i don't care do it
in fact more power to you if you want to
vote to abolish police yeah do your
thing man
i don't live there they don't kind of
worry about it seattle didn't they and
then they were begging for minneapolis
and then they were begging for them to
come back right yeah yeah yeah
law enforcement you know what that sound
when uh what's what's the joke
it's like uh i forgot how you phrase it
but
you know in the apocalypse the people
without guns are just collecting food
with people with guns
you know yeah it's funny you say that
because it reminds me i used to watch
that show doomsday prepper
on uh whatever it was history whatever
whatever
channel and uh i remember this one
episode there was a woman
um she was like you know 300 pounds
grossly overweight and she she was
building this prepper community
they had like maybe 10 or 15 people that
were all part of it and they had five
years worth of food stored
and she kept saying how they're they're
pacifists and you know we don't have any
weapons here
you know i teach self-defense and they
showed a couple clips of her
doing her self-defense none of it was
any good
and you know a proper lady yeah i i mean
as a
brazilian jiu jitsu black belt i can say
that it was no good
and i just kept thinking to myself you
know
basically you guys are just collecting
food and water
for the first group of able-bodied armed
men that show up at your place and
decide to take your stuff
yeah and uh i it was
it was just it was mind-boggling how she
she seemed to have thought out every
other piece
of the pie but that one was such a a
gaping hole
and like what you know you you're the
basically the modern-day quakers more or
less you know yeah you're not gonna
harm anything and uh ultimately
you know it's crazy right now for you in
in the end
these cities are going to be and i
wonder if it's going to be relatively
soon to be honest
there was a uh the cities are going to
be wastelands you know the people are
going to be eating each other
i don't think the right regular people
understand it and i think
so many i mean look at houston right now
houston's grocery stores look like
venezuela and yeah
they've been without power for a few
days it's a bad ice storm
only it's not even a week it's horrible
and there's no food
listening to uh you know various
podcasts and and radio on the way in
it's all because the truckers can't get
in you know this
they can't get in because there's too
much snow on the roads too much ice
and as soon as the trucks stop the
city's grind to a halt
and that's when reality sinks in it's a
scary idea man
um within a few days these cities are
without food what do these people do
what happens if right so right now
you've got relief you've got aid
federal government will intervene in
some capacity to get food to people
people will find their way in but what
happens if there was a total collapse
not that like people would be dying or
anything but just like let's say right
now
there was a disruption of some sort that
resulted in
the trucker supply line ceasing and the
federal government
unable or unwilling to intervene what
would a city like new york do within
three days
no more food food spoils food is
is is consumed people got to eat every
single day what happens
assume worst case scenario something
like commentary impact
volcanic eruption global catastrophe and
it rains for like
20 for like 100 days straight or 20 days
straight or something
floods the entire country everywhere
over earth gets flooded
and the government can't get to every
city it just cannot the federal
government is equipped maybe for one
city maybe
in houston it's not even equipped it's
going to be brutal you can't look at
katrina
yeah the floods you can't stop the
floods you can only try and survive it
and so what do they do this is a if if
if look at houston right now within not
even a week the food is gone
and they're you know what i love more
than anything is that
it's a gun state for one thing right
you've got these
liberal liberals not leftists leftists
love guns they're pro-2a
liberals these urban corporate
pro-democrat liberals
are so anti-gun and they're in one of
the most vulnerable
positions because i'll tell you this in
chicago for instance people got guns
a lot of people got guns and the people
who have the guns are typically not
good people they're gangs right
and just you know they're committing
crimes what would happen if chicago got
cut off
you know what would happen if they would
take over that'd be like the new
government
i mean i don't think that's right it'd
be like gang warfare for the city the
gangs
essentially operate like a government to
a certain capacity with their
territories but it wouldn't it wouldn't
necessarily be they would take over
they would take you'd be in your house
some guy would walk up
break your door open and you would have
no way to protect yourself
it's not easy to get a gun in illinois
right so it's easy for the criminals
because they can hop over to indiana buy
them bring them in because they don't
care about breaking federal law or state
law they just do not care
now you on the other hand a good
law-abiding citizen you're in trouble
now
within three or four days there's no
food left anywhere
power goes out food spoils roads are
shut down nothing's getting in
next thing you know you've got gangs
coming your house and taking what little
food you had left
what are you gonna do people are gonna
get killed people are gonna get robbed
and if you look at say like ukraine
after the fall of the soviet union
you wanna know what happens when there's
a collapse the people with guns this is
what i was told by my ukrainian friend i
said how did the oligarchs become
oligarchs
like these people who just own
everything and she was like oh when the
soviet union collapsed they just shut to
the factories with guns and said we're
the boss now and the workers were like
okay
tell us what to do the workers were so
used to having bosses
within the government that when
everything got shut down the guy
the foreman of the the guy running the
factory is like who do i answer to
all of a sudden some random guy shows up
who's like 20 with a with a bunch of
goons and they've got weapons
and he's like don't worry we'll tell you
what to do we own this place now they're
like
okay all of a sudden now these people
own everything
sounds like government right
to be honest you know most people um are
just looking to follow orders of some
sort you know they want to be told
uh when to go to work when to go to
school what to do
and you know without government then
they'll they'll follow
i mean look at mexico you know you have
basically the government
is the cartels yeah the cartels tell the
government what to do in some cases and
people follow what the car people are
more afraid of the cartels than they are
of the government
definitely i mean people in america are
scared of the cartel sure and the
cartels want to make sure
you know it like i know american
journalists who have had to like back
off of stories
they'll they'll write the dumbest
craziest things about the u.s military
and its politicians and they'll call you
know the president and politicians the
worst names in the world
and then they'll be like i've got i
received a threat outside my house a
bullet was it was in front of my door
because i was reporting on the cartels
and they'll be like well you hear
stories like that
i know some people who are involved in
like activist community stuff who are
like yeah we're bowing out
because the cartels they they're they're
they're not concerned you know
they don't they don't have rules but
luke luke is really obsessed with this
one part of mexico do you remember what
it's called video
i don't remember where they got rid of
government never remember yeah i think
it's
the name of the city starts with sharon
is owner no i think it starts with an m
i was just looking at it the other day
because i was using that argument with
somebody
an anti-gun person and i said you know
look these people got
sick of getting raided by the cartels
and having their people killed and the
government wasn't doing anything to stop
it and so
they decided to take it upon themselves
and
uh tell the cartels to get the hell out
and they couldn't have done that without
being
armed that's just the the the end of it
it's crazy it's it's it's it's funny
when i i i love
i've i've never been through my whole
life a staunch to a
person right now it's funny because i
get messages from people they're like
it's crazy how far
you know pro gun you've gone and i'm
like well look i'm not
an absolutist but i absolutely uh
do think the constitution is important
and if people disagree with the the
broad language of 2a you got to change
the constitution you can't just
pass these laws like they've been doing
but they do it anyway so you know far be
it for me
to uh tell people uh what what what you
know
can't happen when it literally has the
aspiring president but but i love
arguing with people about guns just
because they don't know anything
and so i can be like listen i'm more
than happy to entertain a conversation
about like depleted uranium because
that's a serious question
like if somebody's just walking around
with the pleated uranium bullets and
putting that in the ground even for
target practice you got serious problems
but that's that's a debate that needs to
happen and i think there's some
reasonable
you know concerns about things like that
reciprocity uniformity that we need to
deal with in this country whether
the states don't have you know what if
somebody wants to drive across states i
mean you know and that's a
a problem in the gun community as well
and i'll admit that i sometimes get
uh trapped in those discussions where
you know you you get
you get trapped in these discussions
about the fringes well what happened you
know what do you think about rocket
launchers what do you think about
grenades what do you think about
depleted uranium etc and it's like we
can argue about that all day long but
there are so many things that are
that are banned that really make no
sense okay so like an m1a
yeah like an m1a or for example um you
can have an ar-15 with a barrel that's
16 inches long but if it's 15.9 inches
long you're a felon
you go to prison and not only that if
you own
an ar-15 with a 16-inch barrel
and you also own an ar-15 barrel that's
only 10 inches long
because you're going to build a pistol
out of it in a configuration
that would be legally allowable there
have been people that have been
charged by the atf for constructive
possession because they said
well you owned a an ar-15 with a 16-inch
barrel but you also had this 10 and a
half
inch barrel so theoretically you could
have constructed an ar-15 that's insane
in an illegal configuration so we're
going to charge you with constructive
possession so
i mean it's like who you know who
decided that 16 inches was the right
length why not 15
why not 14. why not 18 right who who
decided that number
well it was decided by the national
firearms act of 1934 and
we have never had a discussion about
that ever since thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time